la plupart des sans papiers se trouve
donc au centre de rétention de vincennes
la police doit il procéder à un examen
individuel individualisé de chacun des
cas compte tenu de leur situation
familiale certains seront régularisés
d'autres quitteront le territoire
français selon des sources syndicales un
premier de charter est prévue demain
matin au départ de l'aérodrome militaire
de creil
nathalie moison et axel charles message
c'est vers 9h ce matin que les 210
africains expulsés de saint bernard sont
arrivés au centre de rétention
administrative de vincennes très vite de
l'interdiction de les rencontrer
signifie à leurs avocats et les
africains ne peuvent pas parler non plus
aux représentants des associations
d'entr'aide se demandent aujourd'hui
quelle est la nature du local qui est
derrière nous est-ce que c'est toujours
un centre de rétention et auquel cas on
doit assister les personnes la loi le
prévoit
ou est ce que c'est devenu un local de
police et à ce moment là les avocats
peuvent jouer leur rôle
oui les sens mais moi je vois je veux
parler à substitut c'est très important
toute la journée les avocats des sans
papiers vont tenter de joindre les
tribunaux la préfecture de police et les
africains eux mêmes
l'incertitude règne sur la situation
juridique exacte des sans-papiers
interpellé en début d'après-midi les
célibataires sont séparés du groupe
direction la préfecture de police de
paris pour y être placé en garde à vue
24 heures une heure plus tard le consul
du mali rend visite aux sans papiers le
diplomate serait là pour délivrer des
sauf-conduits autorisant l'entrée sur le
territoire malien
c'est le signe d'un départ qui pourrait
être imminent je suis avocat j'ai ma
carte vers 18h enfin des chiffres précis
89 hommes sont placés en garde à vue
53 femmes et 68 enfants en rétention
administrative
les policiers s'emploie désormais à
examiner au cas par cas leur situation